could
magic and bird or even jordan do what
lebron is doing today to the league
back in their era
which aspect of it the fact that i mean
you you
if you were if i were to say to you
right now
who is the most powerful figure in the
nba
it's lebron right he has the most power
that nobody has more power in dmb than
lebron he still keeps it now his job is
to stay healthy
relevant do the things that he does and
he's a visionary
he's going to do big things so he's
doing his part but he's the most
powerful guy
but if i told you in 2000
the most powerful person in the nba
would you have said
kobe or would you have said a different
name and if i was to tell you let's go
into 1991
when jordan won his first would you have
said the most powerful person in the nba
is michael or would it be jerry buss
would it have been
another jerry or because it's changing
based on who has the most power
well i'd say first in any era right
there is the commissioner i mean the
commissioner in each of those cases has
tremendous power and because the
commissioner represents the
combined true power and of the ownership
right so they will last
past any player even today oh yeah i
mean if lebron
lebron couldn't take the league down
lebron could
disrupt things and impact business for a
little bit but the league will go on
right and the the sure of course
but when you get into the most i would
have said jordan i mean back in the day
as i
reflect on it in the in the early 90s
when jordan was
in his heyday he was
you know massively uh influential
powerful and
you know global and but he wasn't
and they and he he was the draw because
he and pippin were such a solid base
they're able to
flip all the other pieces around them
and dominate and win
six effectively six in a row because
jordan was gone for two of them
um so he was that dominant as a talent
and as a draw
lebron is it has been different because
he's
wherever he's gone it has followed which
is different
you know jordan was in one place and it
all came to him
this notion of lebron just going
from cleveland to miami four straight in
the finals goes right back to cleveland
where they were literally the worst
and they get to first and they go to the
finals it was you know it's just
incredible
yeah then he does the same thing coming
out here
to la albeit it took a year
um that shows the
i don't know if back in that era jordan
could have done that
because it was a different time you know
they're just people wouldn't have been
able to come with them the way they do
now
yeah and also i mean david stern was a
different animal david stern was a
uh uh he was feared and respected it was
a different uh
uh way and i'm not saying adam silver
doesn't have that kind of a personality
but adam silver comes across
very different than stern did i just
don't know
if if lebron was to be playing in the
80s or 90s
could he have gone around and told
everybody hey if it's not working out
with the owner leave the team hey if
it's not working out with the owner
leave the team like right now
players are just coming out and saying
look i don't like playing with the team
i'm leaving hey anthony davis i don't
want to be with the pelicans i'm leaving
so
if i'm a small market and if i'm getting
ready to spend two billion dollars to
buy a team
say two to three billion dollars to buy
any team in the nba today
if i'm if i'm a small market what makes
michael think he's going to be able to
keep lamella ball for more than seven
years before he goes to celtics or he
goes to miami or he goes to the lakers
or
you know what makes milwaukee think they
can keep giannis for another
four years yeah they just signed a
contract but almost the smaller markets
are being bullied more today
but maybe it's been the same for decades
you're in it what are your thoughts on
it
now that's changed i mean i personally
hate this i hate the fact that you can
celebrate a long-term extension
your giannis example's a perfect one you
know you feel like you got
him locked up you make these incredible
financial commitment all fully
guaranteed the second he signs it no
matter what
and then he can james harden his way out
of here in a year or two i mean hardin
just did it in houston as soon as it got
unpleasant as soon as they weren't
consulting him on every move or whatever
you know it just
he became uh crabby
cantankerous and just and
beau guarded his way right out of his
deal and you know
undercuts the trade value on his way out
because everybody in the league knows
what the deal is
and it's it's a it's a disturbing trend
in the nba
for sure yeah you know all it does to me
is i wonder let's just say if i'm
about about to own a sports team would i
buy a small market or buy into a small
market
not in today's league i i would be very
concerned about being a small market in
today's league it would concern the hell
out of me because
because today it's such a player's
market
that players are essentially bullying
everybody it's
it's full-on bullying they are bullying
everybody now don't get me wrong if we
go back in the 80s
we could say jerry the gm was bullying
everybody on the ball so there was an
element of that taking place
so the the happy medium is kind of tough
to be it's almost like we go far one
side it's
gm or ownership control then we go too
much of a player's side it's player
control but we all know that lebron is
eventually going to own a sports team
you know so so how do you manage that
balance the two
between the player and the owners the
reality today i would not want to own a
sports team today if it wasn't a small
market
sort of depends depends on which league
you're in green bay packers doing okay
right that's the nfl though yeah in the
nfl they're all
profitable because of the way they share
revenues and because of the massive
meteor i agree
so every single team in the nfl is
profitable no matter how bad they screw
it up just look in jacksonville yeah
and then uh in the nba with more revenue
sharing now
the smaller markets have become and with
uh a subsidy from the league effectively
the the smaller markets have become
much more healthy financially and then
you do have some superstars who have
maintained a significant presence in a
small market i mean damien lillard right
now seems just fine in portland
giannis is a good example he's resigned
twice
in milwaukee and they're one of the best
teams in the league because of his
extreme talent
and then of course she had the success
of the spurs for decades
in one of the smallest markets in the
league and the utah jazz right now are
pretty darn good in a small market and
so on and so forth so
all those rules in the league tend to
give those small markets
a fighting chance except baseball you
know that's where it's still just wacky
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye